not a lot of options i'm so glad that we
can admit that i
can't wait for the apology letters to
file flow into president trump down in
florida
speaking of options
eliot page is an actress
formerly known as ellen page i've never
seen any of her movies
didn't really remember that she existed
but then she got a whole bunch of
publicity
because she decided that now she's a man
and her name is elliot and she's now
on the cover of time magazine
chalk another one up to the white
supremacist patriarchy
you had a lesbian woman who was getting
roles in hollywood who had gotten some
attention
and now all of her roles all of her
attention
going to a straight white man that's
absolutely outrageous isn't it
she writes we know who we are
people cling to these firm ideas about
gender because it makes people feel safe
but if we could just celebrate all the
wonderful complexities of people
the world would be a much better place
i agree with the back part of that if we
could just celebrate all the wonderful
complexities of people the world would
be a much better place
but people like ellen pay elliot page
now
and people who are pushing this
transgender ideology
refused to deal in the complexities of
people
it is complex when a young boy
behaves in some ways that you might say
are feminine
that is a complexity of lies a
complexity that's always existed and
it's true of just about everybody
it is complex when a woman
has sexual desire for another woman that
is a complex thing because in the normal
course of events a woman would
have sexual desire for men but sometimes
because of the complexity of our world
it's a little different
it is a gross oversimplification of that
complexity
to say that if the boy ever reaches
for a pink t-shirt then he's really a
girl
and you've got to mutilate him and pump
him full of hormones
and make him appear a little bit more
like a girl
that is not complicating our
understanding of human nature
it is simplifying it we know who we
are she says i don't think she does
i don't think any of us do it it comes
back though to these heresies that
pervade modern life
uh it actually comes back to the the sin
that caused the fall of man which is
pride
this idea that i know better than
anybody else
i know human nature better than
aristotle i know
the relationship of the body to the soul
better than saint thomas aquinas
i know the reality of sex better than
um every single person who lived before
like 2004
i i know i know who i am and and it
comes back to this
real error which unfortunately the
reason i mention this here is because
this is an error that pervades our
politics
this error that we own our bodies
we don't own our bodies we did not
create our bodies our bodies are to
borrow a phrase
from rush limbaugh on loan from god
we don't we don't decide when we come
into this world and we're probably not
going to decide how we go out of this
world
we are stewards of this free gift
of creation we are stewards
of ourselves we we have been given this
gift of our self
by god uh we have intellect we have will
and we have obligations
two our creator
our you don't have to go back to the
middle ages you know to to
see these kinds of ideas
and being understood in a widespread
manner you see it in the declaration of
independence
our creator endows us with certain
unalienable rights
and those are wonderful privileges and
as part of that there are certain
obligations and we come together and we
form a polity for these purposes and we
have duty to one another and we
sacrifice and we get these great
privileges hey wonderful
but what elliot page is now referring to
i know who i am i'm really a boy
that is an ancient heresy it's called
gnostic dualism it's the idea
that the body and the soul have nothing
to do with one another so my body i look
like
ellen page looks exactly like a girl but
deep down
somewhere in a non-physical space
metaphysically
she knows that she's a boy and therefore
she's now a boy what's so weird though
is while the left is pushing that heresy
this idea that the physical has nothing
to do with
reality they're also pushing the
opposite heresy
materialism the idea that we are nothing
more than bags of meat
sort of walking around the streets and
we are nothing more than the sum total
of our desires and our desires are not
rational they're just pistons firing in
our brains
so if it feels good do it because
there's no such thing as a moral order
we're all just
stuff and we're going to die and we're
going to turn to worm food and take a
dirt nap someday
these are opposite heresies they are
mutually exclusive
the left pushes them at the same time
for the same reason that we've been
talking about from the top of the show
because the arguments themselves do not
matter to the left it's only the
final goal which is the upending of
society which
until recently was grounded on the true
understanding of what human beings are
which is
body and soul inextricably linked in
this world
the technical term for it from old uncle
aristotle is hylomorphism
where there's this spiritual component
to who we are this metaphysical
component and there's also this physical
component i do have a body i do live in
space and time
that is the only idea you're not allowed
to hold according to
the radical left these days because
that's that's the only idea
that's true halsey
who i don't i don't know who this is i
think she's a youtuber
uh she is a and a pop singer i don't
know
she's someone who has a blue check mark
and is fairly prominent
she is now changing her pronouns to she
and they she slashday on on social media
bios and this is receiving a lot of
praise
i mentioned this one not not to talk
about it too much only only because
we're now not only uh having you know
he identify as she we're also having
objects identify as subjects right or
in in the uh actual uh uh language
jargon
we're having the accusative case
identify as the
nominative case because you'd think if
she's gonna do
okay she's she that's like okay she does
this
it would be she and them right because
she
usually it would be she slash her
but now it's she slash day so now even
that
last rule that you know objects even
that one's gone now
pretty soon the bios will just be blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
because
you can see it advancing in real time
words
are losing their meaning which is
ultimately the goal so that we can't
reason
the orwell writes about this beautifully
in 1984 he says
the the ingsoc regime the big brother
regime thrives
on all sorts of things you know changing
the language through new speak and the
surveillance
but especially through double think the
idea that they will
the regime will force you to hold
mutually contradictory ideas
in your head at the same time so in your
head you've got to hold the idea that
2 plus 2 equals 4 and 2 plus 2 equals 5.
let's say just to
pull an example out if you hold those
ideas in your head at the same time
it makes you unable and unwilling to
think
rationally if you have to hold the idea
in your mind that
our true selves have nothing to do with
our bodies and
our true selves are just our bodies and
nothing more and you have to hold those
your head at exactly the same time you
can't think
rationally and that is ultimately
ultimately the goal because what
political correctness or wokism or
cancer culture whatever you want to call
these left-wing ideologies or
left-wing instruments they are
ultimately less about the arguments
they're making
than the imposition of the rules that's
why the pc jargon changes all the time
doesn't really matter which jargon
you're using
it's the imposition of it can these
ideologues
weaken your understanding of the world
so much
that you are vulnerable for them to
impose their will not their intellect
not their arguments but their will
on you if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation
historical revision and screaming about
the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
that you never miss another video
you